[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's bring in the ohio state head
coach
ryan day in his second full season as
the buckeyes head coach coach thanks for
joining us
what game film are you looking at today
well we got in early we started on the
hoosiers so they just give us a few
extra days i guess it's
uh been crazy it's been frustrating but
uh you know we're just gonna move
forward and
worry about what we can control and and
on the in indiana
when did you hear the news that the game
at maryland was cancelled
yeah it was a about 15 minutes before
our team meeting we always meet at 2
2 30 um you know for team meetings uh
each day and
about 15 minutes before you know gene
let me know
and so we we relayed the information to
the team and um
yeah just a tough day for our guys if
you could schedule
a replacement game would you yeah
because i look back at nebraska coach
and i i was told that there are other
schools in the big ten that
said hey you know what we may be facing
this scenario as well
that a game would be cancelled and you
need to have that resume
bulked up a little bit were you in favor
of nebraska being able to play
somebody outside the big ten if a game
was canceled
yeah i was you know i actually i said
that publicly but
um especially when it's hard to look at
your team in the ai and tell them they
can't play when they've done everything
you've asked them to do
i guess you chalk it up to 2020. um i
know it's not
as easy as just saying hey let's just go
schedule a game there's a lot of
implications and different things that
have to go into play so i totally
respect that but
but certainly would be in favor of
trying to figure out a way to get it
done but but i also understand the
complexity of it all
yeah and i i was wondering if your
coaches had been able to talk to
the big ten about this uh or can you
have a conversation now
because you may run into this another
time before the big ten title the game
yeah you know we had a lot of
conversations leading up to the season
uh
weekly meetings with with the big ten
coaches i mean
so many zoom calls i don't even know how
many we had but it was a lot
uh but then once you get into the season
it's hard because just all of your
attention and time goes to winning the
next game
getting the guys ready for practice so
it's hard to carve out time to have
these type of conversations we could
pretty much leave that up to the ads and
administrators
um it just your time gets tough during
during the week
you got a good sense of how good your
team is
not really no i mean i uh i think we
have a chance
but without having um spring ball
without having pre-season
without the non-conference games there's
a lot of snaps that our team didn't have
and so we're trying to play catch up and
get going with these snaps and
so i don't know i think we have a chance
i think we have some talent but
we need to play we need to play games we
need to make mistakes we need to work
through those things and learn
and we're you know the only way to do it
right now for us to play a little bit of
this catch-up is to practice better and
practice against each other
nothing take you know replaces games but
we got to do everything we can
in our power to practice and make sure
every rep in practice is a game rep
um but you know i think this game this
week looking forward to to maryland was
an opportunity to take the next step
we'll just have to keep working and
take that next step against indiana what
did you think of tonga by law
you know i thought he was playing well
the the last couple games i
think you know they did a great job of
getting the ball out of his hand quickly
um especially in the last two games i
think he's got some pretty talented
receivers
um and he just kind of has a little bit
of that it factor
and it was going to be you know we're
looking forward to playing them uh but a
lot of respect for that family
they're pulling uh yeah something
magical about those
let's do that he's uh ryan day the ohio
state head coach if a scout called and
said tell me what justin field's
best trait is what would you say
i think that's what makes him special is
there's there's several
i think when you look at him physically
he's he's big he's strong and he's fast
he's got a strong arm
but he has some some just in accuracy
that uh
is special and you know i don't you
can't teach things like that
uh he's just he he sees it it makes
sense to him spaces make sense to him he
can anticipate what
his receivers and defenders are doing so
accuracy is big
but then he also is very very
intelligent and he can
you know take a meeting to the field
pretty quickly so i think all of those
things combined is what makes him
special
i had a scout tell me it's hard to
assess ohio state
quarterbacks and not just ohio state but
other programs
because there's so much talent around
them is that a fair
i don't know if you get this or you will
get this i don't
i watched dwayne haskins against
michigan at home
those receivers were wide i mean it felt
like he could do whatever he wanted i
didn't know how to assess how good he
was or is and i think justin fields will
probably go through that as well
can you see where scouts are going to go
how good is he but how good is the team
around him
i mean i think we have a lot of talent
and i think that um you know we do have
good pieces
around them but that's um that's why the
scouts get paid a lot of money
it's the same thing we recruit
quarterbacks in high school
if they come from a good program you got
to project the best you can and try to
figure that part of it out but
um but we do you're right we have good
players around and that certainly helps
what do you look for though is it
tougher do you think to see a
quarterback playing in the nfl or
quarterback playing in college
when you're when you're recruiting
um you know that's a great question i i
think the high school part
is probably the hardest because we don't
get to spend as much time with them
where in in college you know these guys
come in they work them out
they uh they really spend time with them
they get to know them they can really do
anything they want with them physically
they can the scouts go and watch them
play in games we we don't
and especially now with with everything
going on with covid
um we don't get to see these guys play
live and we really we don't get to work
them out either
we're lucky if they come to our camp and
then we just try to do the best we can
to figure out who they are as people and
watch their film
so i think it's a it's a lot easier to
project them into the nfl
now they still have to go play man
there's there's a lot that goes with
that and that's not easy so it's not
easy for either
situation but it's it's hard in in
college because you just
you don't really get to go work people
out you don't get to evaluate them in
that manner and so
uh it's it's difficult your players know
that you played quarterback in college
uh some of them do i don't think all of
them i don't think some of them know
exactly right
either but uh but some of them certainly
do what kind of quarterback were you at
new hampshire
um probably chip would probably uh
describe
maybe as an overachiever great athlete
um had to figure out ways to uh make it
work because uh
wasn't where it wasn't as talented as
some of the other guys um which is
makes sense probably why i'm a coach
trying to figure out the angles and the
way to try to find an advantage
so uh but uh yeah the the first three
years of playing was was the first three
years of chip being that the
um you know a coordinator and cutting on
the the
no huddle and the spread was kind of in
in its infancy
and so i was a guinea pig some some days
it worked some days not so good
so and i have some of the scars to show
but uh but it was fun to be around
and uh the chip you're talking about of
course is chip kelly who was offensive
coordinator there at uh
new hampshire how often like on a daily
basis
how often do you hear about michigan
uh a lot i mean it's it's just part of
our life
i think not uh you know kind of being in
isolation of your home
and and then being in the woody here uh
it's a little different you don't get to
see
as many people anymore but like last
year
how how how often you're on the street
your grocery store
wherever you are how often are you
hearing about michigan yeah that's all
that's every day
it's it's at my son's bus stop it's um
when wife goes to the grocery store i
mean
it's it's every day
i love it but i grew up with it uh i it
but i don't have to hear it every day
like you do
oh yeah it's uh it's the number one
thing i mean your number one job when
you get here is to
is to be the team up north and then
everybody comes after that
and so yeah the anxiety builds you get
closer to the game for sure
well you got a lot of time to figure out
indiana there and uh
thanks for joining us coach we
appreciate your time good luck the rest
of the season
no thanks thanks it's great being here
it's uh ryan day ohio state head
football coach